[Música]
a
época é
eu
cheguei como terra fértil escura assim
tema mais uma filha de Maria tipo
Madalena e que Jesus meu pai você lembra
a cachaça que quer que Júlio madrugada
abandona orgulho Brasil localidade
paralelo 30 dizem que a vida segue em
curso não reflita a cinza Barro Vermelho
berço de vilões do Mundo Encantado
rainhas de lixões promessas e se
invisível não queria ser feliz noturna
sem saber pra onde correr nisso timidez
com baixa estima
[ __ ] a maldade trabalhe eu era uma
menina onde me abasteço Morro da Cruz
hipertenso pode me reconheço onde no
esmoreço se perguntar para mim o que me
faz seguir ouço baixinho minha mãe
dizendo mude isso aqui cheiro de Mata
Verde perguntaram pensamento dos
moleques sozinho em casa para mim a
tormento para ela e para nós
já tá do tipo rápido nessa cidade de uma
rua só um
eu digo não vou dividir o meu lugar é
aqui e eu nunca vou sair
eu vou seguir assim eu vou seguir assim
e o meu lugar é aqui e eu nunca vou sair
eu vou seguir eu vou seguir
salve gente então se a minha vida
virasse um filme com certeza a trilha
sonora seria Maria Madalena vou contar a
história da minha família Começando na
verdade diretamente do vento e da minha
família quando a minha avó e as minhas
tias quando era muito pequenas e a minha
mãe vieram para Porto Alegre para
comunidade do Morro da Cruz para o
cenário da Via Sacra
eu tô contando sem nada a ver a Sacra
porque é um espaço de peregrinação onde
Todo ano na sexta-feira Santa milhares
de pessoas sobem a comunidade de Morro
da Cruz com suas promessas e com seus
pedidos
e para começar a falar dessa história da
minha mãe que se repetiu quando era
minha história eu começo a falar a
história do lixo na comunidade
Olha só quando a minha mãe era pequena
as minhas filhas e nós na nossa geração
a gente ficava numa força e só quando o
caminhão do lixo chegava na comunidade
do Morro da Cruz e desejava tudo que
tinha tudo que vocês pudessem podem
imaginar de brinquedos ou que a gente
achava que era brinquedo que a gente
transformava em brinquedo vinha daquele
lixão eu e meu irmão quando a gente era
muito pequeno e vários primos e crianças
que eram também na comunidade e um pra
que lixão catar coisas e criar
brinquedos numa dessas Tardes Quando
estava voltando para casa
e começou uma briga terrível lá em casa
Oi e eu fui para o meu quarto e também
minha cabeça de que ela escondida a
minha mãe dele tava muito e começou a
chamar pelo meu nome pedi Socorro para
mim e eu continuava ali
tapadinha eu sei que vocês vão até estar
se perguntando se eu não fui ajudar
minha mãe quando era necessário quando
ela me chamou mas eu quero perguntar
para vocês também se em algum momento da
vida de vocês já ficaram paralisados de
medo
É nesse processo todo de ajudar minha
mãe a Curar as Feridas dela
e ela começou o plantio comigo dizia
muitas vezes todos os dias filha não
casa filha tu não nasceu para limpar a
bunda de branco filha estuda minha mãe
uma mulher semi-analfabeta faxineira
moradora da comunidade do Morro da Cruz
ela e todas as mulheres do Morro da Cruz
tinha esse trabalho
de ser empregadas domésticas e os homens
trabalhavam com limpeza urbana eram
lixeiros então vocês pode até perguntar
mas será que ninguém na comunidade
decidiu escolheu ser alguma outra coisa
que não fosse isso eu conto não com
vergonha dessa profissão que a minha mãe
nos criou muito bem e dignamente mas
porque eles não tiveram alternativa eu
fico adolescente com 17 anos eu conheço
a cultura hip hop
encontro o meu lugar no mundo
Ah e tudo aquilo que eu tinha de
questionamento no mundo eu colocava nas
minhas letras com 19 anos para vir que
eu tive um filho o Eric veio para minha
vida como uma benção Mas também como uma
luta durante esse período que eu fui mãe
até o ele completar 45 anos eu tive um
bloqueio no rappi e não produzirá um
bloqueio literalmente criativo longe
2012 eu pego a mochila pego o Erik e sai
de casa
eu vou morar numa casa bem precária na
comunidade mesmo onde foi cedida para eu
e o pequeno ficaram né Essa questão de
fazer trabalho voluntário circular pela
comunidade eu ensino a visita do marido
Comunitária que disse que tinha um
presente para nós e nos entregou uma
chave peguei o Eric sai correndo fui até
o espaço o presente que ela tinha para
tinha para usar uma casa abrir a porta o
Eric Saiu em disparada em direção ao
banheiro segurou com as duas mãozinhas
dele o vaso olhou para mim disse mãe e
se não vai cair né eu lembro muito bem
que 2012 foi um ano que todo mundo
ficava falando que o mundo ia acabar o
meu recomeçou
e nesse mesmo ano e não tem na
universidade em função de uma outra
política pública primeiro eu falei para
vocês uma política pública de habitação
e agora eu vou falar de uma política
pública chamada ProUni que permitiu que
eu fosse a primeira da minha família a
ingressar numa universidade
Oi e a partir disso esses inquietos como
esse corpo e quieta junto com vários
outros e quietos da comunidade começamos
um círculo de cultura e arte o sábado
cultural que basicamente é o seguinte a
gente não tava caixa de som alguns
materiais de grafite e ia para uma rua
da comunidade e ali se instalará o dia
inteiro começava Lá pelas nove horas da
manhã a fazer oficina de grafite oficina
de rap e ao longo do dia além do mural
de grafite a gente ia também trabalhando
com a questão do lixo que quando eu
contei para vocês o lixo é algo muito
marcante na nossa comunidade
e o gente passava o dia todo ali
dialogando com a comunidade limpando
ambientalizando lugar quando chegava no
meio da tarde vinha artistas de vários
lugares naquele palco aberto para se
lembrar aquela comunidade cantar mostrar
a cultura mostrar a arte e esse
movimento girava dois impactos primeiro
para esse artista que muitas vezes não
tinha lugar para mostrar a sua arte não
tinha espaço no Sat e a comunidade
estava colhendo todos o segundo o espaço
ficava totalmente modificado então nessa
perspectiva também de autoestima de
embelezamento de um lugar que era
invisível e a comunidade ficava feliz em
e nessa não é só lógica de construir
várias várias opções sábado cultural a
minha mãe essa que eu comecei a contar a
história dela no começo dessa fala
Comprou um terreno pertinho da casa dela
com sozinho da Faxina e olhou para a
gente viu a gente naquela construção do
sábado cultural e muitos equipamentos e
disse gente tem ele tá ali Aproveita e
consumo que vocês quiserem a partir
disso a gente começou a falar com vários
amigos que doaram Materiais de
Construção mão de obra e começamos a
construir um espaço cultural
e no ano passado em função de uma outra
política pública que impactou também
diretamente no território a gente
recebeu o recurso de uma lei chamada
Audi Black e a gente conseguiu finalizar
a construção da nossa primeira sala
multiuso daquele terreno que a minha mãe
comprou o console da Faxina dia treze de
Março lembro como se fosse hoje a gente
fez a primeira ação de graça que te
pintou toda a casa e a gente abriu o
primeiro Centro Cultural da comunidade
do Morro da Cruz
falar dos no galpão cultural que é uma
casa de hip-hop que ele tem por si só a
gente a sua filosofia da cultura hip-hop
de cidadania de partilha pela busca de
direitos civis
ele é uma casa de acolhimento onde as
crianças da comunidade assim como eu
quando era pequeno possam ser uma outra
alternativa
eu posso ter um espaço para se
desenvolver através da arte está
saudável e eu acredito muito que espaço
cultural seja um espaço de afeto de
solidariedade de felicidade e que possa
oportunizar para essas crianças que lá
circulam uma nova perspectiva de vida
uma nova perspectiva de Mundo Muito
obrigada
E aí